next we have dekhti Giovanna with seven
bridges he's a program manager there his
PhD was developing closed-loop
brain-machine interfaces using
reinforcement learning for control at
the University of Florida he was a
postdoc at the eth zurich senior
scientist at the EPFL in lesson working
on vestibular prosthetics and the
neurophysiology of locomotion don't ask
me to say that three times fast he
joined seven bridges in 2015 and has
been working in program management for
the API to help researchers automate and
extend genomics metagenomics analysis he
also contributes to national projects
including the million veterans program
and the cancer genomics cloud thanks so
thank you alan for that kind
introduction thank you very much to the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to come and speak to this audience today
this is my first data summit and I have
to say it's really been tremendous
hearing all the different talks and
getting to meet you guys at lunch and
dinner I'm going to go through leveling
the playing field for cancer genomics
I'm from seven bridges we are a
biomedical data analysis company and our
mission is to connect the world's
healthcare data to empower research and
improve health so how many people in the
audience are familiar with genomics oh
this is wonderful it's a it's a big
crowd I still have to what will be
obviously very childish slides for you
then I was going to give the cliff notes
of how DNA works but before I get
started it's my privilege to acknowledge
the huge team behind this effort so in
the bottom right there's a Star Wars
scroll of all the people who have been
involved in the last year I specifically
want to point out Brandi who leads our
product department and was the
scientific program management manager on
the cancer genomics cloud Dennis Corral
our CEO co-founder of the company and
the p.i on the ground Yelena and vlada
did a lot of the work that I'm going to
present today they're on the end
whole metadata team wrangled this
information and they made it more usable
and then Kody and the VIS team build
some things on top of the data model
that really empowered the data so the
title is cancer genomics but I'd
actually like to frame it in precision
medicine so here's President Obama at
the beginning of last year announcing
the precision medicine initiative and
for those of you who aren't familiar i
can give a little hypothetical example
of precision medicine so i go into my
loop into my oncologist and she tells me
jack you have leukemia what we could do
is use chemotherapy a because sixty
percent of patients respond to
chemotherapy a now alternatively she
could say jack you still have leukemia
but we've sequenced some of this cancer
cells and we've looked at the genetic
variations and i'm going to use the one
next to the president and for example we
found some variations right here that
you have importantly there's a large
population of people with similar
variations and they respond eighty-five
percent of the time to chemotherapy be
so which one would you like to use well
i would naturally pick b and this is the
the sort of the promise the toy example
of precision medicine it's finding the
best therapy for each specific patient
but it's important to understand the
space a little bit give that you know to
slide primer on DNA to figure out what
we're working with here so it's a double
hit beautiful double helix strand here
there's four bases a binds to TC binds
to g a human genome is basically a
string of length 3 billion and you have
this inside of each one of your cells
and importantly more than ninety-nine
percent of my genome is the same as
yours in the same as yours and there's a
reason that they're the same DNA
contains our genetic instructions so
it's telling ourselves how do they
function should they reproduce what
should they develop into there's these
specific differences the one percent
that we don't share account for who we
are so i have green eyes that's because
i have a different genetic pattern
then someone with blue eyes or someone
with brown eyes over the course of our
lifetime we go I forget the exact
statistic is something like 60 mutations
will occur spontaneously fortunately
many of these mutations don't do
anything however some of them may drive
cancer or may drive dysfunction so this
is the landscape this is we have a
four-letter alphabet it's kind of a
three billion dimensional space we have
we want to find similarity between
patients what could we do well it's data
scientist I would jump right in and this
is actually when I joined the company I
was super excited about this we're gonna
bring machine learning I've got my
trusty multi-layer perceptron we're
gonna do all kinds of cool things right
we could use clustering to actually
decide how similar patients are we could
classify use classifiers to stratify
patients predictive modeling of disease
and response potentially a sensitivity
analysis I mean there's a wide range of
possibilities here you could choose your
own adventure now some of you are
already looking at me skeptically and
saying well cool you have tools that's
great but you need data to make this
work to have a chance fortunately we're
in the era of big data so specifically
in the genomic space so here on the
y-axis is the number of patients in
these large databases and we're going to
talk today about TCGA which has 11,000
patients there's also some national
scale projects so genomics England and
genome Asia is at a hundred thousand
patients the Qatar bio bank is up to 350
the million veterans program through the
Department of Veterans Affairs will hit
a million probably by 2018 I believe is
the current schedule and pharmaceutical
companies are also getting involved with
just a few months ago astrazeneca
announcing plans to sequence 2 million
patients in the next 10 years at seven
bridges were really excited to work in a
number of these projects specifically
the million veterans project were in a
collaborative research and development
agreement with them to help them handle
data logistics to empower compute and
develop new tools for genomics England
we're specifically working on graft
technology for understanding population
graphs of
gnadox and today what we're going to
talk about is TCGA so the TCGA resource
consortium stands for the Cancer Genome
Atlas their mission was a comprehensive
and coordinated effort to accelerate the
understanding of the molecular basis of
cancer their genome analysis
technologies and eventually over the
course of about ten years they got to
eleven thousand three hundred patients
spanning 33 different cancers and you
can see here the little icons the little
stick figures each color represents a
cancer so this purple one is pancreatic
185 pancreatic cancer patients this one
that's kind of a pomegranate shade is
1100 breast cancer patients overall
thousands of researchers collaborated to
create a petabyte scale database and the
total cost is it varies a little bit
depending on estimates but this was
about 220 million dollars to collect
this data so I want to go into the
timeline because something disruptive
happened in the middle and it's very
important for the rest of this story
this started in 2005 when the NIH
announced the effort the first funds
came out around two thousand seven and
the data was uploaded in 2010 there was
the first breakthrough paper where they
looked at deadly brain cancer they took
the genetic information just performed
PCA on it and by doing that they were
able to identify novel subtypes of the
cancer and stratify patients in this way
now there's a lot more scientific
results but I didn't want to clutter up
this slide any further if you search for
TCGA in PubMed they'll pop right up and
in 2014 is when seven bridges got
involved as a cloud pilot now the
disruptive thing on this timeline is
somewhere around here when
next-generation sequencing became more
economically viable so when this project
started the idea was take a biopsy send
it out on a chip and maybe we'll look
for a hundred different variants or a
thousand or a hundred thousand different
variants to check okay do I have the
suspect mutations which may drive cancer
when next-generation sequencing came
around it became feasible to say
here's my sample just give me all 3
billion base pairs and I'll figure out
what to do with it so that happened in
the middle and that was great news for
research but it changed the flow a
little bit in this data story so I'm
going to walk you through starting at
the top at the tissue source site or the
hospitals where a patient would
voluntarily give their samples it then
goes to a biospecimen core research
center and if they were doing chip work
they would send it off to the right here
check for those hundred thousand genes
and send it to the data Coordination
Center if it was a next-generation
sequencing they'd send it over here and
it would wind up at cghub and the
researchers are here on the bottom right
pulling from both of these centers
circled in pink and getting the
information so what was the difference
between those centers what was was this
path good or bad well they just had
different information so the data
Coordination Center was the standard
provider it validated all the submitted
data so it had all the called variants
the genotypes the chips importantly it
hauled all the clinical metadata and the
biospecimen data cghub on the other hand
so down the left side of the path had
all the big data so the next generation
sequencing the whole genome sequencing
the RNA sequencing all went there
between the two of them it was an
amazing resource so there was more than
a petabyte database with more than
500,000 files and it's important to
commend the tremendous effort put in by
the researchers in this community to
help converge towards standardized
formats to deal with some previously
unseen issues with informed consent
overall they collected more than 2,000
clinical metadata and biospecimen
properties and at the time it was one of
the best annotated data sets for
research so let's dig a little bit more
into this metadata to see what's going
on at the DCC if you logged in you would
get a table of about ten metadata
properties and you could also if you're
looking at particular liver cancer you
could download all the XML files which
we're showing over here which contained
the remainder of the metadata they were
semi-structured there was slightly
different form
depending on the submitting research
center so it made you have to parse
through them to find what you want and
the patient identifier was a barcode
which was largely formed by the metadata
so depending on the type of cancer the
study the way it was processed that
would be the unique unique identifier
cghub work to improve that a bit by
introducing new identifiers to cope with
the file logistics that was happening
these could be mapped back to the bar
code so you wouldn't have to clear
instance change the name of all the
files if the patient had a metastasis or
something like this and here again you
had a table of information about 20 you
logon you'd see 20 parameters you could
search by but importantly there was
nothing on cghub that allowed you to
directly linked to the DCC and vice
versa so what did this mean practically
for a researcher well let's say I want
to study the drug and stage interaction
in prostate cancer so you know the
stages of cancer center stage 1 stage 2
stage three stage 4 and a drug is a
different chemotherapy immunotherapy
whatever you like well I would first go
to the DCC this was the center of the
processing diagram and say I want all
the prostate cancer files I would then
parse out the XML because I was
interested in looking and I wanted to
set this up I want to look at stage 2
for a particular drug with RNA seek as
the technology so on the DCC I could
parse out the XML files and I would know
the entire cohort of cases that had
stage 2 and were treated with that drug
but I wouldn't yet know what kind of
sequencing was done at cghub so i would
have to map to their cghub identifiers
pull all the data matching those cases
from cghub and only at the end of this
journey I would find out i have n
samples so am I good well I don't know I
don't know the statistical power I need
to fit my models I I would have liked to
know when I was designing my hypothesis
how much data was available to be able
to test it and previously very difficult
but very important query is simply I
would like to know all the match tumor
normal samples this would involve going
through this whole loop twice and large
academic centers were quite good at this
I mean as
by the publications but for smaller
centres that didn't have the
infrastructure to pull it to pull this
data down this was very difficult and
for the general public it was for all
intents and purposes impossible so
that's when the cloud pilots came into
the story and this echoes a couple talks
that we heard yesterday where the
mission was democratized this data share
it with the public make this data usable
now three three entities were awarded
these pilots seven bridges was the only
commercial entity and the numbers to
academic ones the Institute for systems
biology and the Broad Institute so what
did we do in with this data well we
cleaned and harmonized the metadata and
first we wanted to understand what was
going on there so as you Lena described
it to me there are many fields to
represent or paint a clinical picture so
we took a brute-force approach we pulled
all 2,000 of the metadata properties and
we looked at their distribution across
the 33 cancers in the data set we also
interviewed researchers we said okay
what fields are important to you for
your analysis we looked into
publications we got community feedback
and tried to understand what were the
most impactful metadata fields for doing
secondary analysis and data science and
one thing we found was that some metrics
were very useful but mostly unique to
particular cancers for example prostate
specific antigen smoking history and
lung cancer so we have some choices to
make how did we find a unified subset of
this data well heuristic alee we did an
optimization where say we want to
minimize sparsity which means all of
those metadata properties that were only
specific to one type of cancer got
excluded we don't have PSA in in the
data model but we wanted to maximize
usability so if there was a metadata
property that was only involved in maybe
four types of cancer but it was
tremendously important that was included
we eventually converged on 106
parameters organized in 10 entities
which is shown here as a case as a
patient could have a drug therapy could
have a portion and analyte a slide and
each one of these has their own this is
sort of an organizing structure this is
coming from additional design
considerations that there is
sort of a hierarchy within the TCGA so
we wanted to have something similar for
users and we didn't want to hit them
with a drop-down list of a hundred
properties so since we had made this
optimization and we weren't sure if we
wanted to add different properties in
later the choice of a data model was
natural for us we used an RDF because
this allowed us to build on the fly if
we would change the data model it would
be no problem to update the store
additionally we could add new files as
the data set grew or if we merge the
additional data set and it fit our
vision of a graph based search
importantly it handles synonyms fairly
easily so while one clinician may chart
your data as a heart rate other
clinicians might chart it as HR or BPM
beats for a minute so we can trivially
handle this with an RDF and it's a
critical capability for future expansion
and we built the whole thing on top of
blaze graph which is an open-source GDL
tool summarizing we came up with 49 case
properties you could think of these as
phenotypic information 47 biospecimen or
bio bio marker bio data properties and
10 file metadata properties so it's cool
to make that model what were we able to
do with the model so as was our original
goal this was enabling precision
medicine I want to show the data model
just because it's really cool I really
like this graph it's a partial
representation so we have a case entity
in the beginning as you zoom out you can
see the case has a gender has an
ethnicity has a history links to other
entities like files and you can zoom out
and see the whole picture here so if
you're comfortable writing sparkle
queries this is great you can easily
pull any cohort you want in this set up
but some of the visualization we put on
top of this made it even more powerful
so in this video I'm going to click
through there is the number of cases or
patients on the y-axis across the x-axis
is each different cancer I'm going to
click on leukemia and what you'll see as
soon as I click on it the distribution
of patients will change
down here and you can see I have a just
about an equal distribution of men and
women they're mostly white the peak of
age the most frequent ages in the 60s
and two types of samples were collected
I can also scroll down if I wanted to
look into the specific experimental
strategy that was used I see here
leukemia is selected and there are about
5,700 files for a genotyping array let's
say I'm not interested in leukemia but
I'm interested in the whole genome
sequencing I can click on that and it
will rearrange telling me there's almost
800 files for head and neck squamous
cell carcinoma I can switch easily to
data type or data format and this
answers the question that we've had in
the beginning of just practically do I
have enough files to do the research
that I want now besides the total number
of files it's interesting to look into
this sample and phenotype question so
here I'm looking at our data browser
we're going to click on TCGA click on
the case entity and here I want to look
at breast cancer so I pull down to
diagnosis disease type and click on
breast cancer it's going to update the
table of files by executing that sparkle
query as soon as we click a new entity
I'm adding in clinical cancer stage so
I'm gonna look at stage 1 stage 1a and
stage 1 beat add that property in it
updates I now want to add a sample type
of blood derived normal so I go down
until I find sample type select blood
did I derive normal and finally I'm
going to look for particular files that
were generated by whole genome
sequencing so I go to the file entity
grab the experimental strategy and
select whole genome sequencing through
doing this and I'm going to refresh the
counts here in a moment I can see very
quickly that I have 17 of the 1100
patient 17 of them had this particular
combination of blood-derived normal and
whole genome sequencing there's 36 files
that I can pull now why is this
beautiful besides the colors and besides
you know
that we see this quickly we found out
yesterday and Barnes talk that there's
only tens of people in the world who can
write Sparkle queries this interface is
actually much easier right so anybody
what has the power to go in I mean it
takes a little bit of time to understand
the organization but you can click and
select this data if we wanted to go from
the example I get started with of a tomb
of a tumor normal pair it's simply
adding another branch to the query and
this execute a logical end and now we
have these data so we have the 36 files
for each type now where this gets even
cooler is let's say I Jamie wants this
data I want to give her this data we
have these files how do we do it well
it's not huge data like I heard about
yesterday but it is over a 100 200 gigs
per file so I'm not going to pass this
over on a flash drive and I don't want
to melt your laptop when you try to do
compute on it and this is some of the
additional power of the cancer genomics
cloud so I'd encourage you to check it
out cancer genomics cloud org in this
case the data can be immediately copied
into a project so this is like an
organizational structure or a folder you
could think of it where you could share
it with your collaborators we also offer
scalable compute instances and more than
200 bioinformatics tools which we've
curated from different publicly
available tools so you could do
secondary analysis but probably even
cooler for this audience you can write a
convolutional neural network in Python
wrap it in a docker image and then run
your own tools right on this cloud as
well and perform analysis right there so
this was the potential what have
researchers actually done so from our
about we we launched the beta in
November we open to the public in
February we have about a hundred users
right now and this is highlighting what
four different groups have come up with
with this data they've identified novel
epitopes across cancer samples a
different group has begun predicting
survival from tumor heterogeneity
and importantly whether this is
dependent on the cancer type or is an
artifact of the variant caller another
group is detecting novel gene fusions
from RNA seek with near-zero false
positive rates and finally there's a
researcher comparing viral infection
patterns across cancer types and the
relationship to outcome i added a logo
on the bottom of a SHG this is a
conference in vancouver in a couple
weeks where these results will be
discussed in more detail if anybody
wants to dig in coming to the future
what we were excited about of course is
federated queries so after bringing on
the TCGA database we've also brought in
the CC le which is the cancer cell line
encyclopedia potentially if you're
working on you know breast cancer
research with patients here you might
also be interested to see how are their
cell lines developed from breast cancer
developing so this is showing really the
power of what we can do one of the
challenges could be you know this work
for TCGA because this data set was
really well-curated for research how
does it work when we get into even
bigger and even Messier data like the
million veterans program which is
pulling in the data the phenotypic
information from electronic medical
records but let's not worry about the
future let's summarize what we've done
right now we created a model for TCGA
data unifying these metadata fields and
the semantic triple store facilitates
rapid queries this model will be
expanded so the good news that the CGC
pilot finished and the NCI has since
expanded it we have an additional two
years so now we can think about bringing
in those metadata parameters that we had
excluded really importantly for me
practically for for you guys as well
providing access to TCGA data in this
way allows users to bypass the data
cleaning and data organization stage you
can spend your time forming a
scientifically rigorous hypothesis and
at the analysis stage doing the
statistical analysis to bear out whether
this worked or not rather than pulling
data together downloading data unifying
this is all already done for you cancer
researchers are already finding novel
results and as a plea to the community
we really encourage data scientist like
you guys to join the fight I want to
thank the team behind the cancer
genomics cloud and give out its Twitter
address in case you want to talk to it
the NCI for funding all of this activity
the TCGA research community for all the
work they did to bring this data
together and create this foundation for
us to build this resource on top of and
very importantly the patients and their
families who donated data to help
advance science thank you